potentially how long is too long when
potentially is it centuries
is it decades
well you know there's information that
goes away i live here in wyoming and i
live next to
members of the crow nation um and if
you've ever had a chance to to talk and
really engage with indigenous people
first of all they're very very private
um two um
they have an incredibly rich history
their their their oral oral traditions
and oral history doesn't go back a few
hundred years
it goes back millennia in fact when
when europe was facing its dark ages and
and
mankind almost went extinct in the
european continent and we were burning
books
you know indigenous people over here
were experiencing a golden era
that wasn't the case over here
and the way they look at nature the way
they look at um
this topic uap is not like we look at it
through western eyes
in fact they don't view it as a threat
at all in fact they don't view it even
as paranormal they view it as as normal
as part of
of nature their natural environment as
real as the the lakes and the sky and
the trees on the mountains are
um and it's just accepted as part of
part of the greater universe
and you know i think i think there's
some beauty there um
you know they're not held hostage by
their by their fears
in fact they they embrace it yeah
and and that goes to show that that you
know you don't have to view this topic
as an either or it doesn't have to be
viewed as a threat or as uh you know um
some sort of of um
saving uh
opportunity for our species um it could
just be a natural part of our existence
um again do i subscribe to that
i don't know but i certainly i i
certainly think it's another way another
perspective that we should consider um
if that is the case and and they're
right then we've been dealing with this
for millennia i can tell you that um
having a chance to talk to some people
in the vatican
you know they describe these these
flaming roman shields in the sky that
would follow them from from battlefield
to battlefield what they call the
eclipse which is the shape of the roman
shield
um you know that's documented that's
there in fact i think if i'm not
mistaken i haven't read it from jacques
valle but from my understanding
jacqueline even wrote a little bit about
that um but i've seen that evidence
myself there there is
there is documentation of these strange
things in the sky going back a long long
time so i don't think it's necessarily
modern um
maybe our understanding is is a little
bit more advanced and may be considered
that modern but i don't think we're
dealing with a new phenomenon i think we
may be dealing with a new recognition
and perhaps hopefully at some point a
new understanding but i don't think this
is a new phenomenon to mankind i think
we've been faced with this phenomenon
for quite some time
you mentioned millennium which is
thousands of years i'm wondering
potentially tens of thousands
potentially millions or do you think
it's cut off around 9000 or so
well that's that's hard to tell because
we only as a species homo sapiens sapien
have been around roughly for a hundred
thousand years and we only really gotten
into written language in the last five
six thousand years really um and been
gone from you know uh hunter-gatherers
to more of an agrarian type society
organized society which is if you take a
hundred thousand years and you
compare the last five thousand years
really only the five five percent of our
entire time rummaging around this planet
has been in somewhat of a civilized
fashion um
you know and then if you look at that to
the context of it's been you know only
in the last
you know thousand years two thousand
years we we understood you know the
archimedes steam engine right and really
didn't even fully appreciate it until
the industrial revolution just a couple
hundred years ago
so now you're talking at you know point
two percent of mankind's time on earth
um
we we've been industrialized we've been
civilized
so how much of our own history do we
really know well you know we can go back
5000 years
pretty easily
8 000 years things start to get a little
murky right and anything much beyond
that
we really have no clue about and the
question is have we as a species been
aware of this
phenomenon much longer well
let's look at what we do know um you
know the general consensus is that the
the the
american population let's say american
army united states i mean north america
south america central american
population
really began about 20 000 years ago with
during the land bridge when you had a
migration coming over the land bridge
and settling this part of the planet but
in reality it turns out now that a lot
of scientists believe that there were
many migrations and many migrations
before
that primary migration twenty thousand
years ago in fact there may have been
multiple migrations going back perhaps
even a hundred thousand years ago
so
um
is it possible that that our our society
um was aware of these things maybe even
interacted with these things in a
certain fashion i'm sure it's possible
absolutely it's possible i mean most of
our history we have no idea about
you know it's it's like it's
it's like spending an entire day and
having amnesia except for the last five
minutes before you go to bed you know
right how was i what was i doing what
did i eat who did i speak to
what did i say
what i'm wondering is what you're
referencing is written history and i'm
curious about archaeological evidence
that you're aware ah
so or that potentially exists it's
interesting
yeah so let me give you a real world
example and i'm not gonna either defu
refute or or defend it but again i live
here in wyoming um and there is a
legend here called the little people the
pyori mountains
and for generations the the indigenous
people have reported uh what appeared to
be this fearsome pygmy warrior tribe of
humanoid type creatures that lived in
the mountains
and for many many many years it was
completely um considered a myth
folklore right yeah
and it turns out that scientists began
uncovering
artifacts up in the mountains that
to some degree reinforced the notion
that there was some sort of
uh
small hominoid type creature
living in the mountains
they found small tools they found you
know
small bones
um
that appeared to be
be coming from some you know human human
human like creature now i don't know
i don't know the details uh but
thoroughly i haven't had a chance to
really really explore it or study it
but that part is true um that that
people are now beginning to look back
and say well wait a minute um
is that possible because we're starting
to find archaeological
um
so
you know
it's it's interesting here i can walk up
into the big horn mountains
and they're pulling out spearheads
spearheads that are 11 000 years old
now think about that for a minute 11 000
years old
if that spearhead could talk what people
did it come from what were they hunting
what did this place look like you know
environments change in a blink of an eye
look at the sahara desert in 5 000 years
you know there was a lot of wildlife
living in the sahara region before it
became a desert and and that was in
recent human history by the way we were
inhabiting the planet when that happened
there are drawings on the side of rock
walls that illustrate uh um
alligators crocodiles if you will and
and and animals that live not just on
the savannah but in the wetlands uh all
cohabitating there
so so this earth is very dynamic um
every time we have a you know for us it
seems like a long time but every time we
have an ice age every roughly 10 15 000
years
the entire topography of earth changes
the climate changes animals change
people change right
um
you know i think it's i think it's very
possible that that there is potentially
some sort of archaeological evidence the
question is would we recognize it if we
saw it
and that's another big big question we
have to ask ourselves
you know um let me ask you this as a
scientist kurt if i said to you um
kurt you have a task
you can make it out of whatever you want
any material you want your goal is to
in a million years
you have to create something now that
will last a million years to prove you
were here
what would you do how would you do it
think about it go ahead
no no no no let's do let's let's i love
you man but we're gonna we're gonna have
this mental exercise right now
i think it's important and by the way
it's not a trick question and i'm not
playing gotcha just what would you give
me just some examples that you might
throw out there to say okay i would make
something out of this or out of that
there are some meta materials that seem
to be harder than diamond so whatever is
our hardest material it would be made
out of that also just so you know i
don't classify myself as a scientist i
i'm more of a hobbyist let's say so
that's what i would do fair enough so
you'd find some sort of hard material
that would outlast just about anything
else on earth right where would you put
it
where would you put it
orbit is one place
okay and hopefully a non-retrograde
orbit right so geosynchronous
and hopefully nothing would perturb but
in a million years chances are something
would but okay hypothetically in orbit
good um
you know here on earth
it's really hard to make anything that
lasts more than a few thousand years you
can even make the pyramids and look at
them now and say wow those things are
five thousand years old and you know
they don't look so great and probably in
another five thousand years they're not
gonna look good at all and they might
last eventually till a hill of you might
have a little
hill of sand in a hundred 000 years but
that's going to be about it and that's
made out of rock right much more same
thing it's going to be gone in in ten
thousand years you won't probably even
recognize it'll be too worn um even
mountains in millions of years become
deserts right um time moves on uh then
you have the subduction zones of earth
that eventually if you wait long enough
on the on the surface of the planet it
all gets recycled anyways it's all going
to get you know sucked down into the
mantle and gets spit out the other end
and as new land so
so nothing is indelible on this planet
it's it's constantly changing and and to
create something that can last the the
sands of time so to speak
is a lot harder than one might think you
know the few examples we have here on
earth
uh that are man-made you can look to the
pyramids you can look at things um
like uh stonehenge
but that's a blink of an eye
that those aren't the those were just
made a few thousand years ago and
they're not going to be around um
you know for for a whole long a lot of
time that's just not the way earth is so
if we're trying to find some sort of of
some sort of marker
chances are you're not going to find it
buried in the earth unless it only
happened maybe the last 5 000 years ago
or so
right even some of the most most
dramatic examples of terraforming let's
look at for example uh the meteor impact
crater in arizona happened 60 000 years
ago
that's already filling in
you know in another hundred thousand
years from now you might not even know
anything ever happened
because of the processes of earth and
what this planet does
it's constantly erasing
what's on the surface and it's
constantly burying what lies beneath
deeper and deeper and deeper until
eventually you know
it gets recycled so
um
you know
it's that's that's a hard question you
know
what would last long enough for us to go
back and say wow this is an indicator of
alien life on this planet 100 000 years
ago
what would you have to do
to to achieve that to accomplish that
it's a lot harder than one might think
and then again would you recognize it
one might say well dna dna is a perfect
example if you wanted to
to do something that was enduring for
humanity that we could look back a
hundred thousand years ago and say yes
that was absolutely manipulated by an
intelligent life form well
deoxyribonucleic acid
uh may be one way to do it you can put
coding and sequencing in there that will
perpetuate over time and time in this
you'll have some degradation over
generations but but in essence you could
do something that way and basically it's
a biological marker right
so we have to be careful when we say we
look for for evidence because evidence
isn't just necessarily
a spearhead found in the bighorn
mountains from 11 000 years ago it's not
necessarily a pyramid sitting in the
middle of the desert
it could be far more sophisticated than
that you said put it in orbit right well
what if if we put that rather than an
orbit we put into the human body
you know
so
anyways that's that's that's so i know
it's a very long-winded way to answer
that question